ABCs of AI B is for vertex AI a machine
learning platform that streamlines the
endtoend ml life cycle from data
preparation to model training and
deployment with a comprehensive set of
tools and services for building
deploying and managing ml models at
scale and unifies data engineering data
science and ml engineering workflows
with features like model Garden giving
you access to a variety of pre-built
models including apis and Foundation
models custom ml platform to help
FastTrack ml model development
deployment with managed data science
tools workflows and impra as well as
generative AI Studio that provides easy
to use and low code tooling for tuning
and deploying large models plus vertex
AI is integrated with other Google cloud
services such as Google Cloud Storage
big query and data Pro making it easy to
manage and access data for ML workloads
make sure to check out some of our other
long form videos on vertex AI to dive
deeper on this topic what other topics
do you want to know more about on the
next episode of